hi there Steve Kaufman today I want to
talk about phrase books remember if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe I
want to talk about phrase books because
as I'm getting ready to go to Bratislava
I want to refresh my check because even
though Bratislava is in Slovakia
I think Czech and Slovak are fairly
similar I want to get a better sense of
the differences but last time I was in
Prague I bought a book like this I don't
know if you can make it out it says just
go on litski Louvre Nick and a move Nick
is a kind of phrase book I found out
slob Nick is Slav is a word slob nick is
a dictionary but Louvre Nick is like a
speaking dictionary and what it consists
of is it's basically a dictionary of
phrases but the phrases are arranged by
words so what are the words what are the
phrases rather that come with you know
whatever you pick up there okay
good day you there be leash you debit
this where do you live
they must get you get yes it to barish
name um debit let and and so for so you
get a whole bunch of phrases which use
that particular word and it has the
English beside it I'm gonna and then I
said myself well this is great I need
the same thing in Slavic so I went to
the publisher Ling gaya online to see if
I could get the e-book and low and
behold i can so i bought a Slovak
English move Nick known in Slovak
[ __ ] or danique but same idea and so
it'll kind of familiarize me with these
phrases in Slovak and then while added I
want to improve my grammar in Russian
and I think would be great to have a
Russian Czech move Nick so that I can
see these phrases in Russian very mind
that this one is designed I think
merely four people are learning English
for Czech speakers or any English but it
works great for me learning Czech and so
if I get Slovak English is going to help
me if I get Russian Czech it's going to
help me so then I said you know it'd be
interesting to see because these are not
that expensive as ebooks and the others
that were offered as ebooks were Czech
Italian and Czech German so I'm kind of
interested in seeing these equivalences
between phrases in Czech and phrases in
these other languages and I can buy them
they're like 9 euros or something each
buy them um ebook style and now I just
got to figure out how I get them to my
Kindle app on my iPad or iBook or
something so I got a little bit of work
to do yet to figure out how I best carry
these with me but obviously it's a lot
better to carry them as ebooks than to
carry you know four or five of these
books along and to me that kind of
phrase book is I think going to be very
useful especially useful if you already
have a lot of exposure to the language
or as in the case of Slovak with Czech
they're very similar languages ah but
the other kind of phrase book the phrase
book that you get that I bought for
example before going to Vietnam or
Myanmar or a long time ago before going
to Portugal when I at a time when I
didn't know Portuguese I have always
found those not so very useful because
it's so difficult to remember any of
these phrases so you can probably use
them if you are actually looking up the
phrase and reading it while speaking to
someone but the idea that you can
somehow memorize these phrases at least
I have not been able to do that I was in
Vietnam for six or seven days and you
know I had this book of Vietnamese I had
some Vietnamese audio I was listening to
there some phrases and at the end of six
days I had only one word come on which
means I think thank you come on and the
only reason I remember it is because
it's similar to come on in English so I
have always found and I have bought a
number of these
I've got correlation phrase books and
gosh knows what phrase books and I find
that you need so it gets back to the
same idea that you need to sort of
upgrade your to develop so much of a
general level of experience with the
language before a phrase book or a
grammar book or or whatever can be
helpful to you
I just feel personally that there's no
shortcut to this massive exposure to the
language and once you have that then you
can go in and focus on traces you can go
in and focus on grammar patterns and so
forth and so on so because I have say in
link I have done so I spent a year on
check an hour a day whatever might be an
hour an hour and a half a day I read a
hundred thousand words
I have 60,000 known words according to
our statistics in link and and
effectively I can read the newspaper and
I understand most of it there's words
that I don't know however to really get
back into the flow of phrasing and
grammar case endings and stuff like this
I have the feeling that going through
this phrase book and I'll be sitting on
that airplane I've got a lot of time I
think it's going to be very useful to me
I wish that we had this kind of phrase
book for other languages in other words
you look up a word in French and Spanish
and in Chinese or whatever and so the
word is there and then ten phrases with
that word and the next word and ten
phrases and on the other side some other
language the language that you're more
familiar with at any rate just some
thoughts on phrase books and I do look
forward to your comments thank you for
listening oh let me add no next time
I'll update you on our many stories
they've been a bit slow in coming
because we are you know working with
volunteers and sometimes we have you
know lessons 20 to 30 but we don't yet
have lesson one to five back in from a
different volunteer but it's going to be
more than 30 languages it's going to be
amazed
and so that's something to look forward
to I know that there are these many
stories in Slovak but they aren't ready
yet once I get them I'm going to do the
mini stories in Slovak so that by the
time I get to Bratislava hopefully I'll
have an easier time communicating in
Slovak okay thank you bye for now
[Music]